hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you hey guess what
my record is gonna run out of [ __ ]
batteries in a goddamn five minutes
Jesus Christ and for some reason as
amazing as this Olympus LS 100 is you
cannot charge and record at the same
[ __ ] time so bill you're gonna [ __ ]
about technology again yes I am in New
Orleans home of the New Orlean nollans
Saints I'm not gonna do a bad New
Orleans accent I hate every time there's
a [ __ ] sporting event down here they
got to go find some Creole [ __ ] guy
sitting there eating crawfish going out
hey Dom County or whatever the [ __ ]
guy it's like I get it I get it they
talk different down here you know they
do that in every stupid goddamn City
every time there's a [ __ ] big game in
Philly they gotta teach me how to order
a [ __ ] cheesesteak anytime that's up
in Boston there we saw some [ __ ]
lobster fishermen say tiya a sailor's
knot I lived there for 27 years I never
met a [ __ ] fisherman ever I didn't
know anybody worked in a lighthouse and
I never went on the [ __ ] Freedom
Trail all right New York City they
always show the Statue of Liberty you
know is that the Statue of Liberty a
bunch of people who aren't New Yorkers
alright cuz this is the deal you're not
gonna go stand in line in your own
[ __ ] City okay you know why because
it's four [ __ ] jerk-offs you know is
it the Statue of Liberty right now a
bunch of [ __ ] jerk-offs gonna stand
up there and [ __ ] it and do a little
selfie and stick your hand out so it
looks like you [ __ ] holding the
Statue of Liberty up as you look up and
try to be cute and do the [ __ ] what's
the doctor evil little [ __ ] pinky T
of you mouth you know or maybe you scale
up it you know so you could do one of
those little [ __ ] squirrel suit jumps
into the [ __ ] water maybe that's what
you do or hang from it by one arm so you
get more Instagram [ __ ] views you
know something I went
eh-eh I went to two basketball games the
last couple nights getting ready for I
got three nights here in New Orleans at
the Mahalia Jackson theater and I went
to the Memphis Grizzlies on or was it
Tuesday yeah Tuesday and then last night
I went to the the the [ __ ] pelicans
game and and that's it with those two I
am done with the NBA I've seen a home
game of all 30 [ __ ] teams plus the
New Jersey Nets and the I saw the
Seattle Sonics at Key Arena
when way back in the day when Kevin
Durant was a rookie I was kind of
thinking as I was sitting there how long
I've been going on the road and all
these [ __ ] places that I went to that
don't even exist anymore like I saw the
Denver Nuggets at McNichols Arena and so
at this point I've gone to a home game
of every football team every baseball
team including the [ __ ] Montreal
Expos and and all everything in the NBA
and I only thing I have left us like
three NHL teams I got to see the the
Carolina Hurricanes the Ottawa Senators
and Ottawa and the the [ __ ] are they the
Vegas Knights that's right and you know
something last night as I was sitting
there with my accomplishment of going to
these [ __ ] games it was just like
it's kind of depressing it's like why
did I do that then I really need to go
to all of those [ __ ] games I mean
that most of the teams wouldn't even
like well when I went to a Golden State
warrior games they had nobody there was
nobody on that [ __ ] team they're
barely in the league and I just remember
the band was amazing and they were
playing a Herbie Hancock chameleon and
they were [ __ ] they were killing it
so I went to most of those games by
myself back in the day when I was when I
would do a lot of college gigs
before young white women ruins stand-up
comedy with their feelings I just want
everyone here to just just stop for a
second and know how I feel after that
knock-knock joke you know I used to do
college gigs all the [ __ ] time and
and these were not prestigious colleges
these were colleges that I could
actually get accepted to so they were in
the middle of nowhere most of the people
commuted and they didn't really have an
area to do a show and how what I would
do to you know prevent from going out of
my mind cuz I wouldn't have an opener I
would just go there by myself and I
would just walk into a cafeteria during
the day and they would be you know
eating lunch and I'd be like hey I'm the
comedian I'm supposed to be doing an
hour here and then they'd be like oh
great and then they'd just walk up maybe
like we got a comedian his name is Bill
Baer yeah here he is that's what they
would do and that would walk on stage is
these kids would be looking up from a
[ __ ] I don't know open-faced sandwich
or hanging out having a good time and
just [ __ ] eat my freckled balls for
an hour and as humiliating as it was it
was never the onstage part it was the
waiting to go on that's what I hated I
hated waiting I just wanted to know I
just wanted to know what was gonna
happen and once you get on then it's
fine even if it's going bad it's like oh
it's gonna be one of these all right but
even if it sucked the fact that you were
up there doing it meant that the the
[ __ ] grains the salt grains you know
a little timer it was it was gonna be
over you were getting it over with you
don't I mean it's like when you have
something in your life that you're
[ __ ] running from if you just [ __ ]
go over and do it no matter what's gonna
happen it's it's it's done it's like
breaking up with somebody like out god
she's gonna cry and all of that [ __ ] you
just sit down and say
hey I'm not happy I'm not happy I don't
want to be in this relationship anymore
and then you did it and then all the
other [ __ ] that happens after that
and as much as it's happening and it
[ __ ] sucks it's it's on its way to
being over
it's way worse before you say it
that's how I always looked at it so I
would just [ __ ] go up there just get
me on stage just [ __ ] well we don't
have a microphone is there gonna be a
problem not a problem not a problem you
know what's gonna be a problem me
standing here thinking about what my
life's gonna be like for the next hour
you know it's gonna be great
getting up there and knowing that as bad
as it sucks I only have 59 more minutes
I already have my check in my pocket I'm
gonna [ __ ] get out of here get my
purple Dodge Neon
I always somehow I used to wear it with
enterprise and that's what the [ __ ] they
had and they were all proud of that car
and now the lens cover on the front
headlights was made out of the same
material as a motorcycle [ __ ] helmet
for some reason they were all excited
about that I don't know why I don't know
what it means but that's where they were
at so I went to the Memphis Grizzlies
and I had you know I'm out of the loop
with the NBA unless the Celtics are
playing somebody and I I didn't hadn't
heard of this this job or aunt guy Jesus
Christ that I but one of the best
players I've seen in forever as far as
like his gait he just decided at the end
of the game this is a close game and I'm
taking over this game and there isn't
there's nothing anybody can do
especially now today's MBA I'm not gonna
lie to you a little skinny guy like that
back in the day catch a couple of elbows
to the chest there when he was coming
down the lane but unbelievable [ __ ]
player I Katie would this I don't know
how to describe it everything how smooth
his jumper was the way he would you know
create plays for you know assists for
other people and then just how explosive
he was how he could jump out of the gym
he just was on a completely different
level than anybody there I felt like I
was watching a college game going this
guy's gonna make the NBA
he is clearly a head and shoulders above
all these other people and he was doing
it at the NBA level and I really liked
the Grizzlies team they were fun to
watch that Jackson junior guy was great
and what's the other guy Dylan what's
his face Dillon Brooks I think he was
cracking me up he plays an angry game I
was watching him it's like this guy's
acting like me if I if I was athletic
from from the beginning of the game he
was [ __ ] yelling at the refs just
completely but they did work for who
else I got Grayson Allen on that team or
I saw over a Duke no what's that
duke-carolina game was just it was a
[ __ ] of great game and it's an
incredible arena and it's a new arena
too and it's still great yeah which is
amazing because it's mostly seats and I
felt like people even when they were up
top we're a lot closer than they are in
a lot of these other arenas where you
got to have sushi bars and all of that
[ __ ] horseshit so we went to the game
we had an awesome time
and then we drove six hours from Memphis
down in New Orleans came out to get our
rental car evidently somebody stole it
so we had to go to the airport and get
another one
it is Memphis you know I know what can
happen and turns out they somebody else
had a gray SUV and they [ __ ] gave it
to them so we had to go there and I
don't know a big [ __ ] big to do that
set us behind oh I forgot this tell you
we went to some studios where Elvis you
know Johnny Cash the guy who married his
cousin all of those guys who [ __ ] all
of those guys have made all that music I
can't I can't recommend that tour enough
I just really it's just I I this is so
few places I've ever got into where you
walk into a room and you like the hair
stands up on your arms it looks the
exact same as when they were in there
and they go that's the door right there
where Elvis walked through what he
talked to the woman who worked there and
the guy who worked there
wasn't there but the lady there taught
herself how to [ __ ] record and cut an
album and here's the first recording of
Elvis Presley ever they said he walked
in and the lady knew he was gonna be a
star cuz she felt like a gust of wind
and anybody she asked who do you sound
like they do know I sound like this
person I sound like that and Elvis is
like my own I don't sound like anybody
else she's like oh my god and then he
went in there and he [ __ ] recorded
this song and the guy who ran it didn't
like it I guess I don't know what
happened next thing you know the guys
[ __ ] a huge star so anyway you two
did Rattle and Hum there and Larry
Mullen jr. left his 1960s era blue
Ludwig kick hit their drum kit there and
when the tour was over I want to thank
the tour guide Graham Winchester cuz he
sat down at piano and I sat down at the
drums in that [ __ ] room great balls
of fire all the Johnny Cash songs all
the early Elvis songs all of that stuff
Chet Perkins all of those sorry Carl
Perkins all of those guys BB King all
recorded in that room and I got to mess
around play a little drums while he
played piano it was [ __ ] head like an
ear-to-ear grin it was crazy
can't recommend that enough man such a
fun City and all these people showed up
on a Monday night I did two shows on a
Monday night just had it could not have
had a better time so thank you to
everybody okay we got a couple of Reed's
here all right
what is honey honey is the free online
shopping tool that automatically finds
the best promo codes and applies them to
your cart and you know how great it
feels to save but how does it feel to
save with honey
saving with honey feels like sliding it
into a seat on the train just before the
doors the doors closed hitting every
green light on your commute finishing up
your podcast episode right as you walk
into work
feel free to insert your own example
here oh geez
scratch finishing scratching your ass
right before couple he walks through the
door without a good one honey has found
it's over 18 million members over to its
found it's over 18 million members over
2 billion dollars in savings did you
know honey
supports over 30,000 stores online
including Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy
and MOA and they're adding more every
day users love honey that's why it's
over well that's why it's it has over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
Google Chrome store all right using
honey feels pretty great think of it as
a daily victory plus it's free to use
and installs in just a few seconds get
honey for free at join honey calm / / b
you are r that's join honey calm / / and
lastly but not leastly policy genius its
January 2020 the year 2020 shows up a
lot in science fiction does it a lot of
people predicted that by now we'd be
teleporting to work or living on Mars
why would you do that why would you go
live on Mars I don't understand people
when I go live on Mars you know what I
mean just go buy a [ __ ] piece of
property in Montana and a lot of those
predictions were wrong the truth is
we're always will always get the future
wrong which is why we need to get life
insurance right
that's where policy genius can help once
you apply the the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape and policy genius doesn't just make
life insurance easy they oh they could
also make they could also help you find
the right home and auto insurance or
disability insurance so it
your science-fiction dreams for 2020
still haven't become science facts don't
get discouraged get life insurance get
life insurance it takes just a few
minutes to find your best prices and
apply at policy genius comm policy
genius will always get the future wrong
but get life insurance right Oh meaning
us is people not policy genius getting
wrong all right that was confusing thank
you
oh and I also took a tour of the kid
hospital there that of course cuz I have
a [ __ ] old man brain now what the
hell is the name of that kid Hospital
the kid Hospital to everybody everybody
this right here is why I don't host
shows because what I'm put on the spot
to have to remember something if it's
not sports related I swear to god
they're like I would literally forget
like my best friend's name like when I
used to host shows st. Jude's they go
when I used to host shows I would I
would write then I would literally write
Patrice O'Neal on my hand because and
then when I said wrote it down then I
wouldn't have to look but if I [ __ ]
didn't write it down
I'd be like bill whatever you do don't
forget your friend's name and then it
just it just disappears
so right there I did talk about comedy
so that my brain would go over here and
then that st. you would pop into my head
so I took a tour at the st. Jude
hospital to see what they do you know
cuz I donate money there every once in a
while you know see if it's the UH
where it's going to it was an incredible
facility and then like there's some sort
of cancer over there it's like you know
when we first started here there was a
ten percent survival rate now it's over
it's 80% I know that's still in that
blood like what are you talking about
that's like eight hundred percent
improvement um it was incredible started
by stand-up comedian right wasn't he
stand-up comedian Danny Thomas I don't
know why don't you get the facts see a
[ __ ] story together before you start
telling stories I don't know because
then this podcast will become work
he's a nightclub comedian singer actor
producer philanthropist whose career
spanned five decades isn't that amazing
bill burr he's a comedian a podcaster
and an [ __ ] whose career has spanned
three decades why she wait 90s
holy [ __ ] him on my fourth decade I'm
really not trying not to think about
this decade do you realize I turned 60
in this decade in 2028 it's [ __ ]
unbelievable what happened what happened
old freckles running down the street
with his fire engine red hair what
happened where did that guy go all right
maybe that's why when I went to the
pelicans game it became so depressing I
was like wait a minute
is this is it because Zion isn't playing
by the way like that kid Jackson Hayes
it's gonna be exciting when Zion gets
back and that was somebody on the
Chicago Bulls who I swear to God I don't
even know how the [ __ ] he's in the leak
I don't even know how the ball goes
through the [ __ ] Hope or like the way
he was running around with his dumb
black sneakers and stuff I just kept
cold look at that [ __ ] guy this
skinny little arms he when he backed up
down the court he just did not look
remotely athletic but he get the ball
and he'd shooting it somehow went
through the hoop it made no [ __ ]
sense you know it makes no sense is why
I'm going a million miles an hour on
this podcast right now why is that bill
oh I know why cuz I want to get home to
my kid and I'm not going to be for a few
days that's been bugging me - I've been
FaceTime and with her and when she gets
on the phone with me she goes dad died
where you live and I still live at home
I'm gonna be home so now she says dad
dad where you working so she goes dad
dad where you living and I was like I'm
in Memphis Tennessee goes Memphis
Tennessee I don't know that she's like
at the most adorable age most adorable
age ever and it's [ __ ] driving me
nuts how much I miss her so I got to
figure out a way to have to have them
come out more often because they they
would had a great time
in Memphis you know we had some barbecue
so what I'm going to talk about that
[ __ ] cuz that [ __ ] is depressing but
this is what I have learned about my
depression is if I just go and workout
or walk around and get a little bit of
air I can get it off me so I don't have
that [ __ ] clinical [ __ ] so I think
that's why when I went to the [ __ ]
pen a pelicans game you can tell I'm
talking about my emotion so I'll say
[ __ ] way more times to keep the emotions
away fright I was just thinking of all
the time that had gone by way back to
like the late 90s when I first started
going to you know games on the road I
saw the Avalanche at McNichols Arena you
know I saw the first time I saw the
Lakers and the Kings they were still
playing at the Forum Bruins at the
Boston Garden the [ __ ] Canadians at
the the old the second forum the Brewers
at County Stadium the Astros at the
Astrodome I saw the [ __ ] Seattle
Mariners that the was at the Kingdome
when [ __ ] what's-his-face was still
playing centerfield who ended up on the
Reds ken griffey jr. I should do that
someday try to figure out how many I've
how many teams I saw that moved and how
many actually that's what I should do I
should make a list of that and maybe
that can stop make me stop thinking
about what I'm feeling right now anyway
so I got three shows here in New Orleans
but I got some relatives who were
actually are coming into town which is
going to be fun
and I am hanging around to go to the
spending an extra day on the road
something I very rarely do now now that
I got the kid but I had to stay cuz it's
LSU versus [ __ ] the Clemson Tigers
for all the MA
so I was going my call man this is gonna
be a [ __ ] show down here and then it
finally dawned on me right as I got here
I was like wait a minute this is like a
home
for LSU so why would anybody who's an
LSU Tiger fan stay in New Orleans you
know they're just gonna drive over to
the game and so I asked the lady when we
came in I go I go what's what's the
what's the situation here is it packed
ORS I figure it's a home game there's
not a lot of LSU people she goes yeah
it's not a lot and you know the Clemson
Tiger fans are not traveling as well as
we thought they were going through which
happens when you win all the
championships that they have so she
actually said we have we cut the rates
on some of their hotel rooms so if
you're thinking of coming down here and
scalping a ticket this might be the year
I don't know but anyway I think I'm just
gonna go for a walk here and I did a
movie here a long time ago called black
or white and I still kind of remember
the city and I'm just gonna take a walk
around and I'm gonna stay off of Bourbon
Street because Bourbon Street is for
young people and [ __ ] jerk-offs I I
told one the last times I was here but
my lovely wife and we watched a woman in
the middle of the day [ __ ] just a
lake of puke pond we'll say she [ __ ]
puked and then somehow inexplicably she
was so hammered she slipped and fell in
her own [ __ ] puke and this was like
it like 12:30 in the afternoon and it's
one of the hardest I ever left in my
life as her friends were hammered trying
to pick her up it was just my half of it
was my wife was so grossed out you know
it reminds me of when I saw [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that name what's the name of
that what's the name of that Will
Ferrell movie is it Brothers
yeah brothers when I saw that movie I I
was watching it with my mother-in-law
who thought the humor was just
ridiculously stupid and the more the
Dumber she thought it was the heart how
I me and my wife were laughing and she
just kept looking over going you think
this is fine I mean I don't think this
is funny just made it even funnier it's
kind of the same thing so I think I'm
gonna skip that I don't want to watch
anybody [ __ ] slip it in there puke I
can't deal with that right now you know
I had a nice [ __ ] time had a nice
little run here so anyway I got three
shows here I'm working on my [ __ ] this
thing's now blinking it's gonna die any
minutes and this is like the shittiest
[ __ ] internet ID by the way I don't
know what New Orleans has against like
nutrition and trying to be healthy but
like what I was here all those years ago
when I died it was here for the
summertime doing that movie I literally
had to take a taxi outside of the city I
went to a Bed Bath and Beyond and bought
a juicer and then like every Monday they
would they would deliver like vegetables
and fruit to this goddamn city and you
had till about 3:00 in the afternoon to
go in and get some or it was just gone
for the week and everything was like
fried I could maybe it's yummy NIT was
like seven or eight years ago that I was
down here but like maybe they have some
health food restaurants but everything
is just [ __ ] dipped in batter and
[ __ ] fried and I don't know it's just
like I just get a [ __ ] an apple
anybody saying we're gonna [ __ ] Apple
out here so I'm kind of gonna be dealing
with that and the shadiness of New
Orleans if you do come down here for the
game just know this if you are on
Bourbon Street with all the other young
people and jerk-offs this is gonna make
people not want to go to New Orleans I
remember a long time ago I went out I
went k-mer I went to the Patriots
verse the st. Louis Rams greatest show
on turf Patriots never won a Super Bowl
I was at that one and I also went to the
one when Brett Favre took his helmet off
and went wee up the field
I saw him recently on the end of the NFL
Channel was trying to claim that
everybody thought I took that helm
enough to draw attention to myself what
I was actually doing was something else
and I figured what he said he was doing
but it so didn't make sense I'm still
like no you took the helmet off because
your agent probably told you to do that
so you could run up the field and go get
a [ __ ] sneaker deal or something I
don't know I mean Joe Montana one way
more Super Bowls I never saw him take
his helmet off and run up the field
anyway plowing ahead here so I was down
at Bourbon Street
just taking it all in and there was all
these people screaming show your tits
show your tits all that [ __ ] which I
don't even know if you can do that
anymore
now with post me too and post partum and
post [ __ ] woke and all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but that's what was going
on so I'm down there cuz like any other
guy I'll see some tits for some plastic
beads let's see what's gonna happen and
I looked over and there was this guy who
looked like Burt young it wasn't burnt
young for the record he looked like Burt
young and he I'll never forget he had he
had a shirt on this white button-down
shirt that was untucked with these black
slacks on and he was standing next thing
he was like leaning back like almost
like in yoga when you try to reach up
and lean back and stretch your psoas
right and sort of thrusting his hips
forward so I looked down and he had a
belly so his shirttails were out and I
looked and he had his entire [ __ ]
junk out dick and balls and I just was
like oh
he screamed it right he's got his dick
out he's got his dick out right like
[ __ ] what's-his-face Eric Roberts in
Popa Greenwich Village right cop [ __ ]
his pants
I just kept yelling he's got his dick
out and I gotta hand it to this pervert
emotionally the way he handled it he
didn't make a big deal he just slowly
turned and just slipped into the crowd
and disappeared and that was it I mean
what was I gonna do I was gonna go over
there make a citizen's arrest on a guy
looks like Burt young who's got his
[ __ ] pre-war [ __ ] dick and balls
out I wasn't going to do it and I
remember being after that walking down
the street I was with my buddy and we
were just like what the [ __ ] and we were
laughing and [ __ ] you know because
perverts were funny back then you know
they weren't something to write a poem
about on a [ __ ] award show right and
I I just got this this vibe on Bourbon
Street was just like as long as we stay
on this street we are fine but if we go
down any side street for more than 10 or
11 feet like we're gonna have like a
[ __ ] razor up against our neck that's
the way it felt back then I don't know
if it's still like that but if you do
come down to New Orleans there are a
great bunch of great places to go to I
wonder if I some of these places still
exist I got this this [ __ ] did this
thing just shut off did it just shut off
no look at this I think I'm gonna make
it let me see here I got this this
[ __ ] I don't know what you call it
you know he just typed notes I think
it's called a note called places to go
and let's see what I got for New Orleans
I remember my wife Mae always made fun
of this she's like it's called places to
go right just make it fun of me and [ __ ]
and then one day she came on the road
with me
and I opened the app and we went to say
okay Commander's Palace dos DOS jefes
was a great place to see this is all
[ __ ] that is off the beaten path Willie
Mae's Scotch house for fried chicken
gonna have to skip that those are the
three that I have here so what I really
learned was how to get off of Bourbon
Street Bourbon Street is great if you're
young you got to go do it and all that
type of [ __ ] but like that is every city
has their Times Square where all the
tourists and jerk-offs go and you want
to get as far away from there as humanly
possible if you've never been to New
York City I mean I guess go to Times
Square but you're not missing anything
get the [ __ ] out of there you try to go
like where the locals go then he can
find like the cool spots we can actually
chill and I remember that dos jefes
place I don't know if it's still it's
what is it je F es they had cigars in
the back and they had this killer
[ __ ] bad as my spell on that right
now it still exists would you look at
that live jazz New Orleans cigars that's
the spot man still open look at that I
[ __ ] love this city you wouldn't know
because I keep making fun of Bourbon
Street but once you start to learn where
the hell to go outside of the city it's
[ __ ] amazing so anyways what's today
today is Thursday oh I will be doing
another podcast before the big game
so my under this guy cool ass hat with
the cigar playing a [ __ ] accordion
only New Orleans could make that cool
everything's cool then how do you make
an accordion cool this guy somehow did
let's see here let's see what the spread
is LSU Clemson spread all right
LSU - five and a half I don't know about
this one
I have no idea I got it I got a I got a
bad feelin Clemson's gonna win i want to
LSU if I got a bad feeling the Clemson's
gonna win but I really believe in a
dozer on and I think he's gonna come up
with the game plan to win but I just got
a feeling that everybody's taking
cleanses for granted they keep [ __ ]
winning it whatever nobody gives a [ __ ]
everybody loves the Joe Borowski
and I don't know I've been down here
before and seen an incredible upset when
the Patriots beat the st. Louis Rams
because for some reason they decided not
to use Marshall [ __ ] which I will never
[ __ ] understand in a million years
[Music]
anyway by the way what's all this [ __ ]
everybody's talking about Tom Brady I
don't understand it everybody like
saying you know the amount of people
that blame Brady I just you know it's
like he won the Super Bowl last year are
you really telling me in in [ __ ] six
months all of a sudden he forgot how to
play the game like I just don't
understand people and I also don't
understand people stalking the guy on
his social media and trying to read in
between the lines of what the [ __ ] the
guy means or what he doesn't mean it's
his career it's his life he can do
whatever he wants to do if he wants to
come back he wants to play somewhere
else if he wants to retire you know any
sports fan has any problem with that guy
that guy's the greatest quarterback of
all [ __ ] time he can do whatever he
wants and if you're really a an
intelligent sports fan it was a [ __ ]
privilege to watch it and if it's over
it's over if it's continuing its
continuing I put on ESPN because I
wanted to watch some of the [ __ ]
highlights and they're doing this whole
big long thing about the guy and so he
retweets this it seems to be that he
suggested that but you know what you
don't need a distraction here you know
with all the craziness of world events
here the financial terror
of the fact that we I think are
considering to starting our fourth war
you know I got a buddy in mind god bless
him he goes dude I think this country's
about ready to go to war it's like buddy
we've been at war
we're fighting three wars right now and
then we have a bunch of other skirmishes
we're involved in and where you are
[ __ ] bankrupt and we're looking at
maybe going in on another one so I could
do the usual dumb thing that
entertainers love to do right blame one
side blame the other and I'm not gonna
do that what I thought about is just
like you know I don't think anybody in
the world wants to see innocent people
dying because of by the lunatics trying
to grab power on either side or whatever
so I think the solution is for me as a
private citizen is to get an electric
car and put solar panels on my house and
then maybe if enough people do that then
[Music]
some of these other people won't be so
fascinated with what's in the ground
over there and then they won't want to
try to liberate them that's it but I
haven't said that I also know it's way
more [ __ ] complex than that so maybe
this is something we do need to do I
don't [ __ ] know but I don't know I
don't know but I I don't know I just
wish everybody would just [ __ ] leave
each other alone just can't you can't
just [ __ ] talk it out I really think
war is super rich people's temper
tantrum and if anybody knows about a
temper tantrum it's me so anyways uh
like I said this is something I just
keep [ __ ] saying everybody just try
to be nice to each other
everybody's entitled to an opinion and
nobody knows what the [ __ ] going on
but you know just try to be cool to each
other you know it's trying to stop all
the screaming and yelling this is coming
from somebody who had a [ __ ] meltdown
in an Apple Store for like the 9000 time
in his life and he's beyond ashamed of
himself
and with that I'll tell you what I'm not
ashamed with my new [ __ ] hour that is
coming together and I want to thank all
the great people of New Orleans who are
going to be coming out to my shows over
the next three days I cannot believe
that I get to play this amazing theater
once forget about three times and you
know selling tickets down south as a
northeast guy was something that took a
very very very long time so to be
selling this amount of tickets is
[ __ ] incredible
so thank you guys so much and I will see
you Thursday Friday and Saturday night
I have the amazing Joe bartnik with me
whose new hours coming together all
things comedy we're gonna be doing a
special with them this year
and I cannot [ __ ] wait it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be a man that I saw
myself in it's gonna be fantastic I just
said it just like the cleaner all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves have a
wonderful weekend and I'll check in on
you on Monday all right that's it what's
going on it's bill Birds the Monday
morning podcast for Monday January 9th
2012 2012 I doesn't sound right
can't wait for this [ __ ] century to
get going you know I need this century
to be over so I can just be why was it
so much easier last decade remember that
[ __ ] hot Cleo you remember how easy that
was
[ __ ] dogs staring at me I got her
over there and her little they call it
takasi that's what the dog trainer said
hey stay there stay Casa it's not a casa
it's a [ __ ] cage okay and the look on
her face is that that's exactly what it
is you know but that's your spot you
stay there I got the door open I got the
door open don't [ __ ] look at me like
that dawg
all right I know where your food is um
speaking of which I went out bought our
brand new [ __ ] big bag of dog food
actually tried some of it horrible
you ever look at dog food you're like
you know then looked at
then you try it you're like wow that
really sucks I can't believe it's always
in a good mood eating [ __ ] like that I
actually tried some now semi emails dude
you know they have pigs asses in there
maybe I like pigs asses you ever think
about that
it ain't gay if it's an animal this is
the Monday morning podcast I hope you
guys all had a great day I'm not sure
recording it's Sunday night because I
was so uplifted because Jesus won
another football game you know and I got
a quote somebody on on Twitter who said
Timbo Josh can you believe that son of a
[ __ ] won another [ __ ] game I'll tell
you what's funny I still don't believe
in him and I know there's a lot of
people out there were like dog he
[ __ ] threw for 300 I don't give up
[ __ ] all right you know what I did one
time what one time I hit an NBA
three-pointer I went behind the line I
threw it up and it went in unbelievable
you gonna sign me
give me a [ __ ] break last week he had
the worst [ __ ] game of his career and
now this week you know you you were so
[ __ ] underwhelmed I just had a big
argument with with virzi because birdie
was saying the guy's legit and all his
type of [ __ ] you know I'm not saying he
totally believed in him but I was just
like are you really gonna [ __ ] do
this to me are you really as a sports
fan Paul virzi are you really gonna do
this to me you really think that this
guy is gonna run the wishbone offense
for like a 15-year [ __ ] career you're
like is this seven eight years into his
career he's still gonna be running like
that he isn't he can't [ __ ] do it you
know they caught up with Michael Vick
real Michael Vick came out remember that
running all over [ __ ] hell eventually
they catch you and they make you pay for
it and you never run like that again cuz
it hurts every time you wiggle your toes
yeah they're gonna catch up to him and
then when they catch up to him then
what's going to happen now he's got to
throw
the [ __ ] ball which he really can't
do go [ __ ] yourself
with yesterday I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] that he made some good
throws yesterday you know it was while
you people who were impressed by Tim
Tebow last week let me tell you what the
[ __ ] it is it's one of those deals where
he's so underachieved that you can't
believe that he actually did the things
that an NFL quarterback is supposed to
do so now you [ __ ] blown away you
know what I mean
it's like when would somebody it was
like when the guy who played mr. Brady
all of a sudden he was in routes like
holy [ __ ] that guy is a good goddamn
actor you know you had no [ __ ] idea
was he really that good in routes Oh was
it because he wasn't going Marcia I
don't think you should kick Jan in the
[ __ ] this week you know I'm sorry
I couldn't think of any stupid Brady
Bunch dialog and I panicked and I went
filthy like I do on stage every night
you know whatever it's just one of those
[ __ ] deal it's like that movie drive
all of a sudden the guy there with
Albert Brooks is playing a tough guy and
you're like holy [ __ ] that guy's [ __ ]
a mate it's cuz you're used to him being
silly it's not that [ __ ] amazing
alright I'm Tim Tebow was the Albert
Brooks of [ __ ] NFL quarterbacks and
that game yesterday against the
Pittsburgh Steelers was his his guest
star in Drive all right the AFC is so
[ __ ] weak this year did you see Ben
Roethlisberger going out there on one
leg he still almost did it
she still almost [ __ ] did it who's
[ __ ] nuts they had like 10 guys up on
the line then they had like one guy back
everybody freaking out because he's able
to hit a receiver in single coverage I
[ __ ] had it
okay stop doing that to me stop telling
me somebody is is the guy because he won
one game alright go [ __ ] yourselves you
know you are all you jackass is out
there in Denver still listening to John
Denver alright he's dead
you don't have to pretend anymore his
music stinks
alright Colorado heat Babbitt Ababu
thank God I'm a country boy really you
really think that we're gonna respect
you as a [ __ ] city like this is a
place that we can bring our computers to
and set up shop you know you ever wonder
why it's still so rustic out there
Colorado you have any idea why it's cuz
we don't respect you you know why cuz of
John Denver and we're waiting for the
day that you guys stop embracing that
[ __ ] the day you do is the day
you start getting respect you know I
know you guys call yourself Colorado you
know what the rest of us call you lower
Wyoming what do you think of that
you don't even northern New Mexico huh
let's test my geography or [ __ ]
western Nebraska No yeah or Eastern Utah
there we go
I'm sorry my dogs just staring at me you
don't want to be in there do you come
over here get over yeah all right no lay
down this [ __ ] dog doesn't lay down
Wow
lay down lay down down you know like
three English words and you always
pretend like you don't [ __ ]
understand them you know what they all
are
there you go that's comfy right you were
in a glass box of emotion weren't ya
anyways so there you go so [ __ ] Tim
Tebow okay he's gonna come in to
Foxborough Massachusetts next week
waiting for somebody to wash his feet
and I'm gonna tell you right now it
ain't happened okay he's gonna be
betrayed 11 times but the New England
Patriot mediocre defense I got me
honestly I'm actually nervous about the
game next week because I just don't
believe in our defense you know when
they talk Patriots what do they talk
about they talk about our tight ends
they talk about Tom Brady they talk
about it's going down to Best Buy and
get video cameras they talk about all of
that but what they don't talk about is
our defense and there's a [ __ ] reason
you know all I can tell you is when you
have a wide receiver starting at
cornerback that's that's when you uh
that's when it's a good time to bet the
over so we'll see we'll see what happens
next week but who's kidding who we all
know this Superbowl champion is coming
out of the NFC right it's coming out
there I'll tell you you know who could
beat anybody is the [ __ ] New York
Giants they could beat anybody I can see
them going into Green Bay and all those
Green Bay fans waddling there [ __ ]
cheese eat NASA's into that goddamn
[ __ ] ball right big plastic [ __ ]
wedges of cheese on their heads just
waddling up every goddamn five-year-old
daughter as big as Forrest Gregg just
[Laughter]
just waddling into that stadium already
all ready for another [ __ ] Super Bowl
run and then what happens
Eli Manning comes in there the kid who
looks like that kid everybody picked on
each I don't know what happens that guy
goes in in the big games he's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] now that guy I'm sold on
all right Tim Tebow I know I know what
he did he picked up that [ __ ]
pillowcase this week and they're like
we're out of footballs and then he set
it up to you with and he kept pulling
all the footballs out right like the
fish in the basket like that other guy
right I'm not I still don't believe in
Tim Tebow I don't I think everybody in
the NFL is gonna look at his [ __ ]
they're gonna figure it out in the
offseason and you know he's gonna get
he's gonna get destroyed next year we'll
see but I don't know he could win this
week that's how bad I think if the
Patriots score about 47 points I think
our defense ought to be able to to hold
him that's I don't know I don't know
what happened somewhere along the line
we just we just our luck ran out
draft in defensive players we haven't
had a good defense
move since like what 2005 there's
anybody give a [ __ ] this is really just
a football podcast at this point I know
everything he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm not into sports well it's not my
fault your dad's a [ __ ] what'd he get
you into huh
meteorology that's a cumulus cloud you
can tell because of the Nimbus I just
threw out names I didn't know what they
are it's one of those things I memorized
and knew for a week and when they asked
me the question I just regurgitated it
back to them and then nobody ever asked
me it again and I never remembered it
and you know what I it doesn't it's not
once has it affected my [ __ ] life you
know cuz they got a whole channel and
nerds that'll tell me my phone tells me
tells me what the weather's gonna be
like I don't need to know that [ __ ] high
pressure system high pressure systems
reading a cold front is it is that
what's gonna happen why don't you tell
me you're a little [ __ ] prediction on
the weather tomorrow alright and save me
the [ __ ] he's bill burr he's mad at
the weather sorry um alright let's get
on with the podcast for this [ __ ]
week as I mentioned and I'm gonna be
mentioning all the time here on the
podcast um if you enjoyed this podcast
do you enjoy it sure we all do and you'd
like to donate to the podcast you don't
have to anymore
all you got to do is if you ever go to
amazon.com cuz you want to buy yourself
some new slippers rather than going
straight to amazon.com just go to
billboard.com
click on podcasts and on the right hand
side right under the itunes thing you'll
see this amazon.com link if you click on
that and then go it'll take you right to
amazon.com you go there to buy your knee
pads or whatever the [ __ ] it is you're
doing alright and they kick me back a
little bit of money it doesn't cost you
a [ __ ] dime all its gonna do is age
your index finger a little bit more as
you hit you click enter a couple more
times you know you go the scenic route
to get to amazon.com and what they do is
they kick me back a little bit of money
like hey Bill hey thanks for driving
people to our [ __ ] site and I say
thank you very much and I tucked that
money right in my front brush
shirt pocket do I keep all of it [ __ ] no
I give 10% to the the Wounded Warriors
Project so there you go you get slippers
I get some money we hook up the troops
it's [ __ ] perfect doesn't cost you
two extra dime I'm not saying I'm just
saying if you go in there
swing by old bill burr calm before you
do that's all I'm saying
stop putting words in my mouth you [ __ ]
all right there we go that's a little
plug for the week Oh actually you have
one other plug you know why because my
podcast is blowing up in the 20 to the 1
to Z it's [ __ ] stupidest thing ever um
I actually have a little I have a little
ad here everybody excited this is
actually uh I gotta let you know about a
TV show that's coming out you guys like
cartoons sure we all do cartoons are
actually some of the best stuff that's
on TV right now for the life of me I
don't understand why you're allowed to
cross so many lines if things are
animated if you have you notice that you
know like you watch a network and you
watch like real people being filmed and
they're only allowed to go so far but
the second you animate him all of a
sudden you can do like some of this
stuff like family guy gets away it's
it's gets away with it's great I just
don't understand why you can't do in a
regular shows but that's the nature of
the beast
so I myself prefer the cartoons as a 43
year old male I can say that I like the
cartoons and there's a new cartoon
coming out that I'm gonna be watching
you guys like that Napoleon Dynamite
movie I [ __ ] loved that movie
you know what's killing me is that it
was art that was in 2004 you know I love
that movie Napoleon what are you doing
today whenever I feel like God right
there I was like I love this [ __ ]
movie alright anyways I'm not supposed
to really curse during these let me try
and clean this up Napoleon Dynamite is
gonna is being turned into a cartoon
series an animated television sitcom and
it's
making its debut on submit season
replacement on to air Sunday's at 8:30
p.m. starting on January 15th 2012 and I
know what you're thinking oh what do
they have they didn't get any of the
original cast members from the movie
they're gonna get a bunch of people that
almost sound like I'm like but not quite
you know like when you go to see a
muppet movie and Jim Henson is dead so
he can't be Kermit and all old guys like
me is sitting they go and that's not
Kermit the Frog that some guy doin
Kermit the Frog to hell with this movie
right
well not that's not the case with the
Khopoli and dynamite they got the whole
cast to come in so it's gonna sound just
like the movie it's gonna be animated
are you really gonna sit there and act
like you got something better to do
alright so midseason replacement it's
Sunday 8:30 p.m. on Fox starting this
Sunday January 15th 2012 22 the one to Z
there we go how was that that was an ad
did you like that Cleo huh you want to
hear my dog moan listen to this this
isn't sexual any dog why are you
sniffing the mic why can't you do that
stop don't listen now she wants to give
me kisses goddamnit you know what your
problem is Cleo you're [ __ ] adorable
but you know when it comes right down to
it when it comes down to it when it
[ __ ] counts you don't deliver you
know you like a quarterback that kicks
ass in the regular season and then all
of a sudden the playoff comes around he
shits the bed you know could you be any
more bored with me Cleo go [ __ ] yourself
alright let's get back to the podcast
umm what do we got coming up here oh I
also gotta let you guys know let's get
all the announcements out of the way I
am taping a new stand-up special at the
Lincoln Theatre in Washington DC on
March 3rd I'm doing two two shows
tickets will go on sale this Friday
January 13th but I'm gonna tweet you
some presale information on Tuesday
tomorrow all right little secret
password if you want to go down there
and look at my big [ __ ] redhead as I
do my my unprecedented
third one-hour special I will be the
first redheaded comedian from the
Northeast ASP Appalachian Corridor to
ever do - ever tape his third one-hour
special in the month of March in
Washington DC you can look that up and
your [ __ ] comedy Almanac alright here
we go let's get let's let's get on with
the [ __ ] podcast alright somebody
wrote here Tigers [ __ ] Tigers wife this
is what she did this week you know I
know a lot of the ladies are all feeling
bad for poor girl oh poor little Tiger
Woods ex-wife still don't know our name
isn't it like a lane she has some old
[ __ ] white lady name what's her name
Edith because with an E Elijah who names
a kid Elijah you might as well just call
your kid please beat the [ __ ] out of
this class we have a new student today
his name is Elijah
Tiger Woods wife just bulldoze their 12
million dollar home which can only have
been out of spite who said it's
sickening to think that think of the
good she could have done with the sale
from that home she could have turned it
into a [ __ ] orphanage or something
but no I was this just somebody ready
here but no she's a spiteful [ __ ]
trying to send a message to Tiger it
served no purpose other than to show the
world what a [ __ ] she is what's worth is
a healthy portion of the female
popularity give her a you go girl
I don't know I don't think she heard her
goal was to show the world what a [ __ ]
she is I just think that she has that
amount of [ __ ] money evidently she
has a twelve million dollar mansion and
she was gonna remodel the thing in a
defense of her you know Tiger [ __ ] on
half of it so she wanted a fresh start
rather than get the [ __ ] thing
fumigated it's a twelve million dollar
mansion so she has this whole thing
plowed
/ just to start over again
she was this okay pull up the marble
I don't want those gold fixtures anymore
Tiger put that gold brass handle in some
hookers ass I don't want that it I'll
just bulldoze the whole [ __ ] thing
can you imagine having that much money
that much money who needs to remodel a
twelve million dollar house I would
think it would be done at that point you
know you got to [ __ ] pools the shape
of both your titties me what else what
else would you [ __ ] need twelve
million dollars so anyways
it wasn't big enough for her so this
woman who's never even won she did even
went on like card sharks or some [ __ ]
game show she hasn't done anything other
than she had the brains to suck the
right dick you know and now she's got
this big-ass [ __ ] house and she
didn't like it so she put she's
bulldozing it over you know it's just
[ __ ] unreal she had a five million
dollar prenup somehow she you know I'm
sick of talking about this [ __ ] guys I
don't have any more fighting me you know
I asked you guys for three three goddamn
weeks to justify to justify [ __ ] dog
just coughed in my hand you know I
thought you snapped Cleo and I was like
oh my god it really is a pit bulls it is
it trying to bite me
um I swear to God I think my dog smokes
cigarettes when I'm not around so he's
[ __ ] hacking all the time I don't
know god bless god bless that victim
Tiger Woods wife I hope she can somehow
keep working through her breakup in her
pain dude how [ __ ] psyched is she she
was married which she no sucks right
she's married to him and what do you
think he was really had a sense of humor
he's sitting around all day talking
about golf
and god forbid when he lost just walking
around the house just cursing at himself
you wouldn't want to be around that
right so she gets to [ __ ] leave and
take a quarter of a billion dollars I
don't have any anger for it anymore I
think I'm just [ __ ] jealous did you
imagine that all you miserable married
guys out there can you imagine if
somehow not only you could walk away
from your wife but get two hundred fifty
billion two hundred fifty million in the
process ah
then they still [ __ ] they still [ __ ]
divorce loss supporter okay all right
here we go here's a guy my defense of
the divorce law I'm sure every once in a
while an ex Bryant and an ex Mosley gets
way too much in the divorce but most of
the people that get truly screwed over
with the divorce settlements aren't the
athletes at the pinnacle of their
professional they are entire they are
entitled pricks now they're not they
make more money than you and you're
jealous what do you what are you basing
that on all those nights you hung out
with Kobe Bryant anyways for every
Mosley there are at least 50 [ __ ] who
grew up in Greenwich and Greenwich went
to Choate with legacies at Yale and make
a mint by wearing $8,000 suits and
screwing over the less fortunate so if
there's rout row fie wives bang they're
gardeners and take half I say God bless
them yet dude you're really not
justifying the law I don't think people
understand the the question I'm not
saying that you can [ __ ] start a
family and just walk away I'm just
saying put a thirty million dollar cap
on it you know unless you can truly
prove that you that that you you you
were there and I got I'm like you helped
out Kobe with this [ __ ] jump shot I
don't know what the divorce settlement
law is designed to screw over people
that will never ever get screwed over
otherwise Kobe and Sugar Shane are
collateral damage yeah see you guys
really can't [ __ ] justify it that sir
you didn't just all I learned in that is
that you resent people who make more
money than you do that's all that's all
I I got out of that and surprisingly
these are guys writing this in you would
think that as men
you know we would if for once come
together on a [ __ ] subject you know I
don't [ __ ] you know I tried I tried to
be controversial I tried to ask you guys
the questions I get I [ __ ] floated it
out there it's not yet not only can you
guys not even [ __ ] give me a reason
to justify you you won't even answer the
[ __ ] question why am i berating them
you know most people probably don't even
give a [ __ ] anymore at this point
including myself alright it's over
gold-digging [ __ ] are a part of the
world you know like skunks hey can
skunks crawl into the garbage they have
the ability to crawl up anything when I
look at them I don't think they do
you know I got one that keeps [ __ ]
trying to sneak in and into my [ __ ]
driveway buddy might drop me off the
other night and the thing was walking up
the street and you should have seen this
him freaking out sky damn skunk was like
30 feet away and I'm getting out typical
white guy [ __ ] with the thing you
know you know kidding quick steps at it
you know tapping into my inner redneck I
got I got 20 bucks and a tooth says he
gets [ __ ] squirted I got a friend of
mine [ __ ] a skunk one time most [ __ ]
his wife had a snicker [ __ ] anyways he
couldn't tell difference we're you don't
want to make some shine tonight no let's
let's make some shine and let's film it
and we'll go on Discovery Channel and
then we'll be ducking behind our still
as they film us on television that's
what the [ __ ] we doing what you love to
be that dumb you know that dumb that you
didn't know any better not to go out in
public my dogs look at me falling asleep
how can I be this loud and bore you know
I would think would just be exciting on
some level even as a dog like maybe
there was an earthquake you know my next
life when I come back I want to be
full-on [ __ ] redneck
I'm gonna be one of those guys who's
like 60 when I first see a pair of shoes
and be like what the [ __ ] are those um
you know everybody thinks I'm dumb and
meanwhile I got a [ __ ] 351 Cleveland
in my [ __ ] lawn mower techsmartt
Scoob I'll tape it got wheels on and he
can fix it they can fix it at both
[ __ ] Aki thought of snake was under it
do you love to be doing that just that
[ __ ] just your mind just open like
that America just out in a [ __ ]
lagoon fishing never going in the
grocery store he's just going out
killing [ __ ] right start rubbing sticks
together and you living like a [ __ ]
caveman am I the only guy every once in
a while you just look at a [ __ ]
trailer in a trailer park and you just
go you know what why not what if I just
said [ __ ] it I'm gonna go be the
smartest guy in a goddamn trailer park
imagine if he came there they probably
resent you I already got a book and that
[ __ ] thing is that a new reality show
it's gotta be is why don't they have one
about trailer parks they already did
that didn't they when they sent those
two rich [ __ ] to go live in the UH the
the suburbs totally ripping off Green
Acres Paris Hilton in that chick from
the who was the daughter of that dude
from the commodores right Nicole Richie
and she lost all that weight and a
[ __ ] the bottom of her bikini was
hanging off her snatch like a [ __ ]
hammock remember that how long ago was
that what happened in the last decade I
don't know Cleo can you [ __ ] believe
I got to listen to another goddamn week
a [ __ ] Tim Tebow everybody amazed
that he actually completed some passes
I'm gonna give me a [ __ ] break you
know they're gonna sit there and give
him all the accolades that they won in
overtime
despite the fact that Titan turned to
[ __ ] 8-yard in rote route into a
[ __ ] 80-yard touchdown can you
believe that Cleo you could have hit
that [ __ ] guy anyways let's get on
with the advice for the week this is an
advice from away dear Belton I've been a
fan for a while now and I remember
hearing on one of your podcast that you
were interested in hearing from more
female viewers or listeners whatever
whatever lady whatever so here I am
hopefully after reading this email you
won't be bored to tears and completely
regret making that earlier statement
anyways let's plow ahead well if it's
not too long ago you know I don't read
that well ma'am did i insult you by
calling you ma'am
that's a very subtle way of saying you
don't make my dick hard anymore so the
next time you're in an argument with a
woman who has power over you like your
boss you know maybe you down the [ __ ]
DMV like I was if you call him ma'am
ageism they don't like it oh why don't I
tell that story about being down the
[ __ ] DMV so I finally went out and I
got a second vehicle you know and went
out bought a used bought a used car I'm
not gonna tell you what it is because it
sticks out like a [ __ ] sore thumb so
I go down to the goddamn DMV right you
know and Nia's going why don't you just
go online and make an appointment so my
god and I go online and you know it's
the usual it's like every possible DMV
scenario it's like go [ __ ] yourself I'm
not doing this
so I get my Prius and I Drive down the
street right whistling down the [ __ ]
Street and I go over the DMV and I come
walking and what do I see every goddamn
jackass in the [ __ ] world to stand in
there then go it's a 20-minute wait to
make an appointment to sit in a
90-minute [ __ ] I said forget it so I
walk up to the thing okay let me get let
me get an appointment they go well the
next one we give you isn't it till
Tuesday next week or
you can go to [ __ ] Pasadena tomorrow
I said alright I'll take that one nine
ten in the morning I will be there
listen this is what I'm doing I just
bought a car I'm putting it on the
[ __ ] Road what do I need and she's
like you need this this and this right
so I go home I get that [ __ ] I wake up
the next morning pour myself a bowl of
Froot Loops and off I go down to the
[ __ ] DMV walk into the DMV I go hello
I am William burn her at the DMV I have
a 9/10 appointment and the guy starts
looking through the thing and he goes I
don't see your name here what is it I'm
like William Fuhrer have a [ __ ] 9/10
appointment don't do this to me all
right please don't do this to me and
then he sees it he goes oh there it is I
was like holy [ __ ] there it is I sit
there and it's like [ __ ] 9:00 in the
morning I'm sitting there for two
minutes and all of a sudden they call me
I was like you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
me
not only did I show up they had my name
not only am I gonna get in and out of
here at nine ten that's ten minutes
[ __ ] earlier at the DMV
this is unfuckin heard of so I show up
and what do they do to me I give this
this and this just like the [ __ ] lady
said and then they go sir did you pay
tax on the vehicle in the other state
and I was like no I didn't then they
tell me I got to get the [ __ ] thing
weighed like you got to be kidding me I
just ask somebody they didn't tell me I
had to do all this stuff and then the
lady was just going like she goes well
sir did you go on our website and I was
like lady every possible [ __ ] DMV
scenario is on your website
I'm not sifting through that [ __ ]
looking for a needle in a haystack I'm
not doing that I went down to the
goddamn DMV I talked to a human being I
asked him what the [ __ ] I needed they
told me I brought it sorry Cleo right I
brought it so she goes I'm sorry sir
blah blah blah and I'm sitting there
trying to get it not to get mad at the
girl at one point I actually started
chewing the collar on my coat that's how
[ __ ] mad I was and I got to tell you
something guys I don't ever get
recognized
ever it's [ __ ] great
no one ever bugs me I don't know why I
just look like a regular jackass second
you take a microphone out of my [ __ ]
hand
I just I blend into the background it's
[ __ ] perfect
so I'm sitting there pissed off I'm
[ __ ] biting the collar on my my
jacket all of a sudden this dude comes
up he's like yo my man I know you a
little mad right now bomb big fan can I
have your autograph
like yeah I sign the thing and now that
lady's good meanwhile the lady's going
you have to go to a public scale what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is a public scale
what in the center of town what the [ __ ]
is that I had to go get this goddamn
thing weighed I don't know why cuz it's
a broke state and they're looking for
another way to [ __ ] me out of a couple
hundred bucks I have no idea why so I
signed this [ __ ] guy's thing they
tell me what to do when I walk out and
I'm walking through the got in the
parking lot just have absolute
Tourette's not screaming but not
whispering just walking out I'm just
going every [ __ ] time I don't
give a what [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you bring
down on these [ __ ] [ __ ] I got
everything here plus a birth certificate
I still run a [ __ ] [ __ ]
flipping out this other guy yo my man
you funny man I'm like oh hey thanks a
lot [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know I realized I think if I'm not angry
people don't recognize me me being not
being mad in public is my hat and
sunglasses that's all I have to do if I
just walk around with the stupid smile
on my face and nobody recognizes me
that's what I noticed that day the
second I lost my [ __ ]
two people recognized me oh that's that
angry redheaded jackass I've seen on the
boob tube then the second I [ __ ] calm
down nobody since then nobody nobody's
come up to me go to a you're that guy
who does that thing that I saw a nun on
the channel not a [ __ ] one of them so
that's my damn V story yeah people
actually I got a second vehicle and I'm
liking it let's just say I didn't get a
hybrid alright I got a little surf and
turf going on if you know what I mean
little make
Elte action uh-huh little you say tomato
I say tomahto go [ __ ] yourself I've done
my part for the environment all right
here we go dear bill this is this is
this lady I'm getting back to the ship
my dog couldn't look more bored I swear
to God if my dog was eight eight if his
if her face was like you know
communicating what you guys are thinking
right now this might be the last podcast
I ever do why you look so bored you know
this [ __ ] thing sleeps all day I
don't get it what are you tired
what are you why are you so sleepy you
see it right now she [ __ ] up her ear I
don't know what she did looks like
somebody bitter you know but she's with
us all the time I don't know when she
did it so we got this big stupid bandaid
on her ear look at you look how sad you
look huh except [ __ ] with you
that big thing hanging off there like
one of those Jody Watley earrings why do
I talk to you Cleo like you're gonna
respond alright here we go
bill I live in Seattle Washington and
actually in Seattle not some lame suburb
that people like to try and pass off as
Seattle I know God knows if I had a dime
for every time someone tried to pretend
like they lived in Seattle anyways I've
been friends with this guy for a little
more than three years now and he is
easily one of my best guy friends now
what does that mean is this like your
gay friend or is this the guy who wants
to [ __ ] you but doesn't know how people
you gotta elaborate with these things
okay cuz my minds just gonna start
thinking he's easily one of my best guy
friends can I ask you a question what
sort of a heterosexual guy has a woman
as a friend if that's not your
girlfriend are your wife in other words
if you're not plowing it every once in a
while can you please explain to me why
why would you do it do you use her to
get more [ __ ] is that what it is and
you meet her friends you work her way
through her friends and she's just like
how could you do that to me I thought we
were friends
we are friends we're friends that's why
I didn't [ __ ] you consider that
a compliment you know other than the
compared to the [ __ ] I did to your
friends you know if you know how much I
know this podcast is gonna come back to
haunt me the level of ignorance every
[ __ ] week is it's ridiculous you know
and whoever's playing this right now
pointing at it going you see I said your
piece of [ __ ] whoever's doing that to me
in the future go [ __ ] yourself you fill
up 60 minutes by yourself and see what
comes out of your mouth um there you go
bill that was a lot of some having a
hypothetical argument about some
[ __ ] in them in the in the future
that's nice so anyways let's get back to
this she has one of my best guy friends
yeah this guy's either gay or he doesn't
know how to doesn't know how to uh [ __ ]
you or he grew up in a house with all
women or you're a dick tease and he
doesn't realize it yet or maybe you're
just friends you know why don't why
don't I try to be a little more pause e
posi a little positive in the one to Z
sorry [ __ ] blew the punchline when
I'm home from college over the winter
and summer breaks me and my guy friend
we hang out quite a bit and throughout
the year we stay in touch there's always
some flirting going on between the two
of us and ever since we first met people
have asked if we were more than just
friends we've done a lot of things
together that other people would
consider would constitute as dates such
as going out to eat movies the zoo etc
yeah if this guy's heterosexual you guys
are eventually gonna [ __ ] or end up
hating each other
when one of you commits to someone
else's genitalia alright moving on here
hell we even went on tour a tour of a
Chocolate Factory and I helped him buy a
new DVD player but in all this time he
has never made any attempts to get out
of the friend zone with me we're really
open with each other but he's always
been rather secretive about his love
life and he hasn't told me any stories
about girls or where he or what he gets
up to at his school in Seattle and
before you say anything I promise you
he's not gay too late too late
but now I'm kind of sick of going back
and forth in my mind about what could
happen between us and I'm thinking about
just pulling the trigger the next time I
see him what do you think should I
continue to wait around to see if he
ever takes our friendship further and
not risk messing up our current
relationship or should I stop being a
[ __ ] man up and go for it in general
how do you feel about girls making the
first move and being assertive in that
sense a male perspective on this matter
would be much appreciated also I'm hella
excited to see your show when you come
to DC in March hella I thought that that
was just in Sacramento that people said
that um all right what do I think about
this this is all right this is a hard
one all right
my gut tells me you guys have hung out
too [ __ ] long and I would think as a
woman like what kind of guy is this you
know this is the guy you want to
possibly hit your proverbial wagon - I
say that word right you know this guy
who can't make some [ __ ] you can't
even make a move and then you have to
make a move this is the guy this is the
guy you're gonna be sleeping next to
when some psycho comes through the
window and you're gonna be laying there
going is he gonna grab the bat or do I
have to do it you know you kind of got
to think stuff like don't you you want a
guy who just grabs you by your [ __ ]
throat and says listen [ __ ] we're a
[ __ ] couple I'm kidding
I don't know I've never had a
relationship like this this is just so
many different directions that this can
go this guy is either
a [ __ ] 30-year old virgin and it's
gonna be the worst [ __ ] sex she ever
had or he's an absolute animal and he's
[ __ ] he's just out there crushing ass
and he is I don't know maybe as a [ __ ]
Madonna complex and you're just a really
nice girl and the thought of even
banging you freaks him out I have no
[ __ ] idea I don't know what to tell
you this is what I say if you really
like this guy and you really want this
just to happen I guess it's up to you to
make the move you know
um I don't know that's [ __ ] weird
though I'm gonna tell you just as a guy
that's [ __ ] weird at some point you
know once you I mean you're doing [ __ ]
that couples do when they're sick of
each other you know the zoo who the [ __ ]
goes to the zoo oh look at that
miserable species sitting in there
trying to remember why it isn't free any
more minutes you know the Chocolate
Factory this guy sounds like a he sounds
like a [ __ ] to me I don't know what
does he do what kind of a man goes to
the zoo with the woman he's not [ __ ]
I just don't understand why would you do
that maybe he likes it is the indie
animals is he is he like an
oceanographer and then anyone do that
you want to go to the zoo it's like lady
I'm up to my ears and [ __ ] octopus
like [ __ ] Tony Montana I don't go to
[ __ ] zoo I'm looking at him all week
you know they should be in cages I'm
[ __ ] sick of them they're animals
yeah I don't know what to tell you this
is what I would say but yeah basically
if you're into the guy and you wanted to
go to the next level he's obviously not
gonna say anything I would yeah [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it throw it out there see what
happens and if it gets weird and you
lose him as a friend who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] what are you gonna stay
friends with that guy when you meet the
guy you're gonna marry you know you
still think you're gonna go to the zoo
with them that guy who actually had the
balls to ask you out he's gonna put up
with that [ __ ] he's not tell you right
now he's not because I speak for all
peoples because it's my podcast
alright plowing ahead number two
wife's put on a few oh jesus this is a
rough one
I mean needed some advice that requires
the presence of the lovely Nia she's not
home right now so all you got is me but
be forewarned the discussion could very
likely lead to you spending the night on
the couch first of all if you think
spending the night on the couch [ __ ]
scares me
all right I live on that goddamn couch
alright and as a [ __ ] man if you
don't spend at least 30 percent of the
nights of the year on the couch you're
not being honest with the person you're
with [ __ ] their feelings 30 percent of
the year the other time other 70 percent
you respect their feelings but thirty
percent of the time you got to tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves
alright that's why I'm telling you right
now if you got to be in a relationship
and you go out and buy couches let her
pick the color but you picked the size
and you picked those big-ass [ __ ]
deep couches alright and lay down on
them and when you lay down on the couch
you make sure there's enough cushion to
go beyond both your shoulders unless
you're a [ __ ] giant man then I don't
know what to tell you but if your
regular size like me okay so then when
she does kick you out what the [ __ ] do
you care you go out there with your dog
he put on ESPN he watched the end of the
Vancouver game you love in life you know
you don't have to wake up in the middle
night rolling over looking at her face
when she's in REM sleep going I'm in
love with that right you don't have to
do that for the [ __ ] thirty thirty
percent of the year all right here we go
it's likely that Neil will find some
strong adjectives to call me at the end
of this but so be it
I have a lovely wife who is an amazing
mother there you go right there
sounds like a Hallmark card she has
supported me through very difficult
financial times and some some emotional
breakdowns Oh what happened huh we knew
the only accountant at work is that what
happened and all of a sudden the feds
came in and you realized you had two
sets of books anyways
let's plow ahead I got nothing at this
point she has taken responsibility for
our personal finances to prevent me from
having anxiety attacks and she is
fiercely loyal I know she is oh you
sound like you guys lost a house did you
guys lose a house during all this this
[ __ ] were you one of those guys
giving out mortgages to homeless people
is that what you were doing you did
something you did somebody it that's
what I'm guessing anyways I know she
always has my back if I were to catch a
break and become financially wealthy
through my career endeavors and then got
divorce she would deserve half without
the without question something you have
a great relationship guys I'm sorry keep
clearing my [ __ ] throat hang on
second he pauses alright i'm back sorry
about that um alright without a doubt
she would deserve half the problem is
she has gained some pounds I would
estimate fifty to sixty of them that's
[ __ ] unacceptable dude unless you date
in a sasquatch
then it's probably cute hey Bigfoot come
on in here bend over the [ __ ] garage
I want to bang you um Jesus Cleo you
know what's great about being a dog is
you will fart anywhere you just don't
even give a [ __ ] she's laying there
right now looks like a [ __ ] baby
piglet she's getting fifty two six and
sixty pounds this has happened since we
started dating and she was and she was
overweight although not that much when
we got married so this isn't due to
having a baby she's such an amazing
person that I looked past it even though
it was a concern now I'm no Charles
Atlas but until recently I've been in
good shape I have begun to get a [ __ ]
attitude and become soft over the last
year since I've always been active this
hasn't resulted in a bit of depression
so I'm returning to the gym for my
sanity back to her weight though her
body has begun to break down because of
the at this added burden yeah dude fifty
sixty pounds is a lot of [ __ ] weight
I don't care how big you are she's
having foot problems knee issues is very
likely candidate for diabetes her
grandmother died young because of her
weight and I fear she has headed down
that same path also yeah absolutely it's
a health concern here now you may be
thinking what a wonderful man this is so
concerned over the health of his wife
that's exactly what I was thinking sir
you've snowed me up until now I'm
totally on your side but he says au
contraire my friend while I wish this
was the driving reasoning become that I
wanted to lose weight um I've heard that
wrong well I wish this was the
in raising because I wouldn't feel like
such a prick it isn't
I am fist physically repulsed we have
sex but to do so I have to make sure not
to look at her body and turn off the
lights it is hard enough to remain
attracted to someone who you slept with
over a thousands of time but adds some
pounds and it results in my pecker
remaining soft like jello um dude you
know I don't think this is look what if
she was in shape and you put on 50 60
pounds and your goddamn man tits were
bigger than her real ones
you know that's it's not you know you it
I I personally I feel being in a
relationship part of his you have to
stay in [ __ ] shape god dammit I wish
Nia was here this would have been a
great [ __ ] fight anyways I know obese
obesity is a mental thing and I have my
own issues one of which is an inability
to communicate my feelings resulting in
pouting brooding and getting grumpy now
Jesus you're walking around the house
mom I won't be fat no I don't wanna [ __ ]
her anymore
come on man he says I really am a pain
in the ass to live with now that I think
about it so the communication in our
relationship is a bit of a problem and
they're therefore a Death Zone should I
strike up a conversation about it it
would be like the opening scene of
Saving Private Ryan should I try to
storm those beaches so what do I do
keep quiet accept it while my wife
likely dies in an early age how do I
support her when it's a topic that's off
the table I'm thinking about talking to
her friend and asking them to broach the
subject I need some advice because I've
already removed a layer of skin from my
penis whacking off to internet porn so
much it just doesn't seem right for a
bald middle-aged man to have his pants
around his ankles in front of a computer
oh Jesus Christ
this is one of these subjects that yeah
it's it's it's always off limits you
can't
you can't bring it up there's no way to
bring it up it's one of those things do
you just know there's gonna be a fight
and just accept it I would just say it
as nicely as possible I would not try to
hire her friends to do your dirty work
you just got to tell it just say listen
I've started to go to the gym I'm
starting to get out of shape just tell
her how much you love her and you want
her to be around and then a grandmother
died of an early age because of weight
issues and that you know you're getting
concerned because she's put on a few and
you know what let her get mad she's not
really mad at you she's mad at herself
you think she doesn't know she doesn't
hear herself breathing every time she
bends down to try to [ __ ] pick up the
cookie she just dropped I'm sorry
you know you got to do it man you got to
do it don't [ __ ] watch that internet
porn that's one of my new year's
resolutions I'm quitting internet porn
cold turkey
I just this [ __ ] it takes to get me off
at this point I swear to god it's like
I've been working on the vice squad for
20 years it's it's not good for you I
really you know it just isn't especially
for a cycle like me the [ __ ] road you
go down you just don't want to go down
it so um yeah I don't know how to you
know what I'm gonna do if Nia isn't here
by the end of the podcast I'm actually
gonna ask her how to bring that up okay
ah [ __ ] now I just said it now I have to
do it I was just thinking what if she
stays out all [ __ ] night comes home
hammered then you know what she's gonna
do a drunk podcast I don't wanna get
your [ __ ] hopes up so anyways that's
what I would do I would just sit her
down just say listen this is one of the
hardest things I've ever had to do
that's a that's a bad way to started
she's gonna think that you haven't an
affair
whatever maybe that's a good thing she's
thinks [ __ ] you [ __ ] somebody else
and then when you just call her a tub of
[ __ ] it'll I should be a relief you know
maybe I would tell her myself tell her
how much you love her and you're just
looking out for her and but don't say
that you know you're repulsed by her
body that's not a good thing you know
you don't want to hurt somebody like
that
all right okay here we go number three
girlfriend and her ex on Facebook dump
her dump her dump dump this [ __ ] [ __ ]
her that's not the mother of your kids
dump her I don't have to go any further
than that girlfriend and her exes on
Facebook yeah it's over dude what are
you [ __ ] 17 how do you how do you not
know you can't trust that girl that's
like you know my partner in crime and
all his cop friends you know me you know
how this is gonna end do I really have
to read this ah what the [ __ ] I still
got some more minutes to eat up I'll
read it I don't need to but I will bill
I've been going out with this girl for
about a year we are in love we're best
friends for about eight months before we
started dating we get along great we
have a shitload in common the Sun always
shines we never burn our bacon but love
my blue anyway she gets along with most
of her ex-boyfriend and still keeps in
touch with them with Facebook's and
texting sometimes she swears she is
never the one that calls her texts first
if that's not the worst [ __ ] excuse I
didn't jump on his dick he stuck it in
me um anyways this past week she asked
me if it was okay if we can all hang out
when her ex comes to visit
he lives in DC and comes to visit a few
times a year their entire relationship
was long-distance dated for about six
months they went to school together and
knew each other she had a crush on him
in school yeah he's coming to town to
[ __ ] your girlfriend that's what he's
doing all right that sounds like the
beginning of a Christmas song I just
switched up the lyrics so you better be
good cuz he's coming to town and he's
gonna [ __ ] your girl down the chimney um
I'm gonna [ __ ] a my um he said that he'd
like to meet he said that he'd like to
meet me for what who is his douchebag
what the [ __ ] does he want to meet you
for
so he can look you in the eye the day
after he bangs your girl and swatches
you try and figure it out anyways he
goes now I appreciate that that she even
told me about this but why would I want
to meet the guy that was banging my
girlfriend months before me exactly why
is he important exactly exactly you're
asking the right questions it's not like
he is her baby's daddy she said that it
wasn't in in my place to decide what do
you think I think she's absolutely right
it's not it's not your place to decide
whether or not she sees her ex
boyfriends she can go decide to do that
the same way you can decide to go get a
woman that you can [ __ ] trust [ __ ]
her sir figuratively and literally in
the ass
get away from her this is a [ __ ]
ticking time bomb where the [ __ ] does
she get off telling you that it's not oh
it's not your decision to decide you
know what go see him dude you know what
you're a loyal guy you love this girl
you sticking by you know you just gave
you feelings to the wrong person she
doesn't [ __ ] deserve you [ __ ] her
doll her [ __ ] ex-boyfriends let her
go back there let me go get that long
distant [ __ ] alright walk away she did
you a favor dude you could have gotten
married and had kids with this [ __ ]
alright it's over dude and you know what
you even know the answer you're asking
all the right questions why do you want
to meet the guy was banging before why
is he important he isn't important she
still has feelings she can't commit to
you she's trying to keep these guys [ __ ]
that [ __ ] her that's it alright did I
make myself clear enough it's over wait
he said background info on this girl I
like this he's actually fleshing this
person out she has a daughter that I
also love the baby daddy is barely in
the picture met him once so no drama
there the reason I bring up the daddy is
because he is important the father of
her daughter I understand why I would
have to meet him but who is this ex to
her yeah exactly exactly come on man you
know don't you go get yourself another
girl who you know doesn't have as many
miles
you know this girl yeah yeah you don't
need that you don't need that alright oh
hey bring it back overrated underrated
overrated under a New Year's resolution
overrated every year we always hear how
so-and-so is going to change their life
in such a dramatic way whether it be
taking school more seriously quitting
drinking or losing weight by going to
the gym and what happens a month in that
[ __ ] is out drinking themselves under
the table and eating a double
quarter-pounder the day before they have
their exam the excuse is always I just
haven't had the time when in reality it
should be I'm just a lazy [ __ ] don't
talk about what you're going to do just
do it I like that underrated hooking up
with a lady because because of Bill
burrs podcast nice look at that [ __ ]
four years then I finally did some good
there you go sir there you go alright
listen to most of the [ __ ] I say don't
listen all of it because I am jaded
alright but if you look in the [ __ ]
tag a lady use the [ __ ] that I say if
you're looking to fall in love don't
listen to anything that I say other than
what I just told that guy with the face
but find someone who deserves it alright
don't be an old crabby dick like me
anyways bill I'm 21 and this is my first
New Year's Eve I was eligible to go out
and drink legally so I went out
someplace with an open bar got
shit-faced and ended up puking all over
myself in my sleep but along the way
there was this girl who I knew from high
school who was a hot broad to say the
least
oh is this the guy telling me the story
how he hooked up okay here we go
now we never really spoke much but since
I was so [ __ ] up I said to myself
let's see where this goes we start
talking and the topic of comedians come
up and we both say our favorite of
course is you sir well verily this
stroke of my ego but what she didn't
know is that you have a weekly podcast
she was ecstatic considering how in love
she is with you dude if she listens to
this episode she might figure it out but
you already [ __ ] her so who cares
right and after I put her on to this
tidbit of information see
to have an even greater appreciation for
my presence long story short midnight we
hook up and many times after until both
of us don't even know our own names now
could have been the alcohol and my
charming personality but I thought I'd
give you credit for having this podcast
sir
oh I write good for you man whatever I
don't think it was me I think you're a
little older and you now have the
confidence but if you want to give me
credit I'll [ __ ] take it I'll take it
just like Tim Tebow is gonna take credit
now he doesn't take credit I gave
everything to the Lord Jesus Apfel the
invisible bearded guy up the sky man he
gives a [ __ ] about the [ __ ] game um
Tim Tebow I give all praise to my lord
my Savior
yes we realize that Tim you always say
that why don't you tell us who you give
all your praise to when you don't give
praise to that because you know until
further notice you guys realize how
[ __ ] I am if Christianity is actually
100 percent correct do you understand
about the [ __ ] the goddamn two
bedroom suite that they're already
preparing for me down and inhales fire
Dan inhales fire you guys still really
believe in that [ __ ] you really believe
that there's a guy in the sky I think
there is I think you know actually I
don't I just think when you believe in
that stuff this is my own personal
opinion you're just too dumb to figure
[ __ ] out for yourself
you know that's why I love scientists
because they don't just sit there you
know when they look at a little volcano
they don't go it's the fire gods and
he's mad at us you know they go all
right let's start digging in the ground
and then they figure out that the core
is still on fire and I'll [ __ ] land
[ __ ] gets created I don't know and
then then they go and then they tell the
Jesus freaks and then they kill him they
kill the scientist they throw them in
make a sacrifice to the fire god then
eventually a few centuries later they
finally agree
all right you got us on the volcano
stuff you know but uh you know who made
the the Earth's core then how can you
answer that one it was the earth core
God like that's what they do no matter
as science just keeps proving and
disproving religion they always no
matter what you say they always end up
with their hand on top of the bat
because I'm thinking whoa who created
infinity man I would [ __ ] and you know
there was an answer to that I don't know
and neither do you
okay so stop trying to put a face on it
and tell me what the [ __ ] I'm supposed
to do
I'm legitimately asking you this if
there was a higher power why would he
create pedophiles why would he do that
if he has the ability and let's just say
that cuz cuz Satan [ __ ] did something
to his wiener alright alright I'll go
with that
then why doesn't God just take a [ __ ]
lightning bolt if I was God I would just
treat earth like a video game I just
start zapping people you know a couple
of casualties here or there you know
that did collateral damage but you make
it up to him you invite him into your
house why wouldn't you just do that why
does he let [ __ ] you know like that
douche over at Penn State why does he
let that go on so [ __ ] long it doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense I don't know what
it is I don't know who the [ __ ] knows
I've lost so many goddamn friends last
five years you know some it's actually
made me not even afraid of dying anymore
cuz I just figured if there's something
else I'm going wherever they're going
and I'll just hang out with them and if
it sucks you know we get all go down
like that Billy Joel song having any
sense
are you guys all asleep right now like
my [ __ ] dog alright let's do a recap
everybody if you gotta go to amazon.com
please go to Bill burr com
first click on the merch page and then
go through Amazon I would really
appreciate that a ton of you guys did it
and that means the [ __ ] world to me
that you did it he took an extra couple
of
cuz before you went there and bought a
Flowbee you know you decided to kick me
a couple you know what I did I actually
bought some skates finally bought some I
finally got sick of wearing my pair of
Bauer Panthers from 1985 and actually I
didn't want to ruin them because they
were starting to get ruined and I bought
him it Hughes's Pro skate shop God rest
his soul and I still have the sticker on
the side and I was like I don't want I
don't want that to go away so I [ __ ]
I I wanted a new pair ones that I don't
give a [ __ ] about cuz I'm gonna I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a big adult kid got no
responsibility I'm a [ __ ] lazy
bastard and when the second I'm done
with this I'm gonna go to sleep with my
[ __ ] dog you know not a bestiality
kind of way now what else
please watch a Napoleon Dynamite give it
a chance man it's on Fox this Sunday
makes its debut this Sunday January 15th
and it's got the entire original cast
with which to me you got to have that
that's awesome that they were able to do
that because like I said is there
anything worse remember they used to do
that remember that like what the [ __ ]
was one of those one of those damn TV
shows you gotta be kidding me I can't
think oh I remember what was that movie
with the Alicia Silverstone and that hot
black chick and they was a little hoary
schoolgirl outlet outfits the [ __ ] was
it called whatever they ended up doing
they ended up doing the TV show and like
only the the hot black chicks signed up
and then everybody else was differently
like this isn't the [ __ ] TV version
of the movie you got all the new people
this is my roundabout way of saying
watch Napoleon Dynamite this Sunday if
you like animation come on man give it a
damn show what else you gonna do are you
gonna watch the 3000th episode of The
Simpsons like I just [ __ ] did that is
a podcast for this week I really hope
the Patriots when that's gonna be brutal
you know what I bet if the Patriots lose
next week it's gonna be cut because of
me and my podcast because I trust I
trashed the bearded baby oh man I wish
wish I recorded the argument I just had
with virzi / tim tebow he wasn't by any
means saying that the guy was a great
quarterback but you know he's the exact
opposite of me
you know he's one of those guys that
gives he will give somebody credit
beyond credit like he was the guy when
Sanchez had those first three great
games he was like dude he's a [ __ ]
star and I'm always the guy going you
haven't proven [ __ ] to me yet in other
words Paul virzi is a great father and I
should never have kids and with that
that is the podcast for this week
this is what I'll do if Nia doesn't show
up in a decent amount of time I will
just ask you the question next week and
I will do it in my own rude style so
even if she doesn't get mad she'll get
mad at me and it'll be some more laughs
for you guys so once again thanks to
everybody's been going to amazon.com
like I said kicks it my way and then I
kick it 10% of it over to the to support
the Wounded Warriors Project how do you
not support that right that is it that's
the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves don't take any [ __ ] man a
woman if you're on Facebook and you got
the [ __ ] smartphone it's ok in the
end they're [ __ ] talking to their
exes dump them it's over you know what
they're doing you know what they're
doing right don't [ __ ] ask me you
know what they're doing alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves
you